it may seem improbable but many coastal
tidal marshes are drowning shamone
Anna's felled director of a
four-year-long research project at the
Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies has been
monitoring long island sounds tidal
marshes the tidal marshes are critical
to maintaining wildlife habitat and
coastal communities drowning marshes are
areas where we're losing the vegetation
we're losing side of the base of the
food chain the high productivity the
organic material that provides food for
the invertebrates and then the
vertebrate consumers it's ultimately a
degradation a loss of those habitats is
a loss for for the wildlife that depends
on them in addition marshes are thought
to provide an important buffer for
coastal communities against storms
against erosion and as those marshes
themselves are eroded and become open
water systems become tidal mud flat
systems they provide less than the
buffer they don't slow water down as
much sea level rise is or overtaking the
ability of the marsh to keep up so the
sea level is rising more rapidly than
the marsh surfaces rising professor anne
is felled and his team created plots in
guilford and Westport Connecticut to
test whether fertilizers are causing the
drowning what we're doing here is we're
we're actually manipulating the marsh
we're adding nutrients that is we're
adding nitrogen and we're adding
phosphorus sort of fertilizer to the
marsh to see what happens and that is
really to test the hypothesis to test
the idea that too much nutrients is a is
bad for the marsh and can lead to
drowning the possible links between
adding nutrients and drowning are really
twofold we know that adding nitrogen to
marshes will increase the above-ground
production increase the the plant
material that you can see and that's not
going to lead to drowning but our
concern was that it would lead to less
productivity below ground that is less
organic matter less material growing
below the surface and that it would lead
to higher decomposition rates that is
greater loss of material below ground
those two combined or even separately
could lead to less material
in the marsh in the marsh Pete in the
marsh sediment in the marsh soil and
lead to degradation of the marsh and the
logic is simply that the plants use the
roots to get nutrients if they have
higher nutrient available to them they
don't need roots as much so what we set
up here at this stable Marsh were a set
of 24 plots and they were divided into
four different kinds of treatments so
four different things we did one was a
control where we didn't had anything
just monitored the marsh second type of
treatment was adding nitrogen and
monitoring the marsh third was adding
phosphorus and monitoring and the fourth
is adding both nitrogen and phosphorus
together professor Anna's Feld suspects
the lack of sediment rather than the
presence of nutrients could be
contributing to Marsh drowning so what
we've seen at least so far is that the
nutrients certainly make a difference in
terms of the above ground productivity
as we expected and as other people have
shown adding nitrogen does lead to
higher above ground production and you
can see it actually very clearly in the
marsh the nitrogen fertilizer plots or
taller more productive than the controls
and then the phosphorus for less plots
in terms of the below ground which is
really what we were after we didn't see
large differences so at this point we're
not inclined to think that nutrients are
an important part of the of the drowning
equation and we're looking for other
explanations I think we want to look at
next are the ideas that came out of the
first phase of this project which really
did not support the nutrient link but
rather pointed us more in the direction
of inorganic processes that is the
sediment that is being delivered by the
tides the hydrology of the marsh we're
going to continue the fertilization
experiment we want to kind of pin down
the effects of the nutrients here but we
don't think that's the main cause of the
drowning Marsh drowning may be the
result of sea level rise which will
accelerate as the world gets warmer sea
level has been rising in Long Island
Sound for for thousands of years since
the last glaciers were here and as the
glaciers melted a lot more water went
into the sound and that water warmed
over time and so sea levels been rising
in Long Island Sound the water was
rising at about a millimeter a year and
then about 150 years ago at about double
to about two millimeters a year it seems
pretty clear that
that global warming that anthropogenic
climate change is leading to a warming
of the oceans which is going to lead to
an increase in the rate at which sea
level rises for more information about
professor Ana's Feld's work and the Yale
School of Forestry and environmental
studies visit environment yale edu